-Congratulations on the show
I feel as though you guys have
pulled off a very hard thing
which is you've made a ver
funny show about grief
that is also
very honest about grief.
-Well, thank you.
-And you just got picked u
for a second season,
which is excellent.
-We did. We did.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You and your co-star,
Christina Applegate,
you guys are fantastic together.
And you're both going throug
sort of different
kinds of grief.
And you're both pretty much --
I've only watched
the first couple episodes --
you're pretty much
in every single scene.
Is that accurate?
-Yes.
When I read it, I thought,
"Oh, it's two female leads
That's so exciting. And I'll
also get some time off."
But no, it was all of us,
you know,
both of us on set all the time
-And we were talking backstage
I'm so familiar
with both of your works
because you have
such a large body of it,
but you guys had never
worked together before.
-No.
-Did you know each other at all?
-No, we did not know
each other at all.
-It's fantastic.
Your chemistry is fantastic.
-Thank you.
-And it is a lot of fun
to watch.
It is very funny, like I said,
but there's also
a lot of crying.
-Yes.
-Very good cry acting
on this show.
-Thank you, thank you.
-I was taking note of it,
because I'm like, "Wow.
They are both crying a lot
and in very different ways
and I'm very impressed by it."
-Yeah, yeah. It's like all
different versions of crying
-Yeah.
-Yeah, a lot of times --
-I've also heard
you were a cryer.
In real life, you cry
at animated films.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I cry a lot anyways
-I feel like because, maybe,
of what we do, I am more -
I'm taken out of the reality
when I watch acting.
But somehow when I'm watchin
animation, it breaks my heart.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then I -- I was watching --
I've done it twice.
I've cried so hard
during "Finding Nemo."
-Uh-huh, yeah.
-That was the first time
that it happened.
That somebody --
And then during "Up"
that somebody next to me said --
asked me if I needed to leave.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "No, no.
I love this movie."
[ Laughter ]
But yeah.
-One of my first dates wit
my wife was "Toy Story 3."
It was a 3-D.
And I was wearing --
she still has a picture of me --
-"Toy Story 3" killed me.
-Yeah.
And I'm crying with,
like, big, dumb 3-D glasses.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And she took it from the side
And I'm just, like,
this weirdo with, like,
a tear coming out of
the side of my face.
It's a pretty bad scene.
-"Toy Story 3," somebody told me
that at the end, Woody died.
-Uh-huh.
-So the whole time I watched it,
I was expecting that
that really happened.
[ Laughter ]
So I was hysterical from the
very beginning of "Toy Story 3."
-Why would somebody tell -
-No, he doesn't die.
-Yeah, but why would somebody --
-I mean, that's a spoiler.
Sorry.
-Why would somebody tell you
that awful thing?
-I don't know. I don't know.
-Was it the person you ruine
"Finding Nemo" for?
-Yeah, no kidding.
[ Laughter ]
-"Hey, when you see
'Toy Story 3,' Woody dies.
-Yeah.
Last time you were here,
you were in the "Avengers,
but you were not allowed
to tell anyone.
-No.
-And you kept the secret
pretty well, yeah?
-Yes, yes.
-That's very impressive.
-Thank you.
-And was it true that one of
your friends just found --
fully found out
watching the movie?
-Yeah, one of my childhood
friends was --
because I didn't
tell my parents.
I didn't tell anybody.
-Yeah.
-And one of my childhood friends
stood up in the middle of th
theater and yelled and pointed
"That's Linda!"
And then, he was with his kids
and his kids
were so embarrassed.
[ Laughter ]
-You have a 7-year-old?
-I do.
-And you -- have you introduce
her to any of your work yet?
-You know, not too much.
Not too much.
But she -- you know, at on
point, kids were talking about
"Scooby-Doo," and I said,
"Oh, do you want to see that?"
And she said,
"Mommy, that's weird."
[ Laughter ]
So, no.
-What did she find weird
about it?
-I don't know.
-That a dog was a detective?
-I didn't go into it.
I was like, "Oh, phew,
she doesn't want to see it."
But she did once see
a commercial for "Green Book,"
because there was a lot of
commercials running.
And I have an accent.
She was like,
"Mommy, your voice."
[ Laughter ]
So sometimes
when I read her a story,
I have to do, like,
Dolores' voice for her.
-Oh, that's really great.
I like that,
that she just was very impressed
with your skills as an actor
-Yeah.
-Your ability to transform
-That's all that matters,
is to get her approval.
I make her watch everything,
give me notes.
-And was it --
I guess she's seven,
and when you did "Mad Men,
that was another sort of
top secret --
-That was crazy top secret, yes.
-But being top secret for
"Mad Men" was maybe even
a little bit harder
than the Avengers,
because you had to have,
just playing the role,
you had to be, like,
era-appropriate --
-Yes. I had to have these
incredibly long, acrylic nails
I mean, they weren't supposed to
be acrylic then.
They were supposed
to be natural nails.
But long nails were
very feminine at the time.
So I had a four- or
five-month-year old.
Not, year-old.
-Yeah.
-Five-month-old.
Whatever it is.
She was young, I was tired
I'm a mom.
[ Laughter ]
And I would change her diapers
with these ridiculous nails.
And I'd be sitting there
with other moms,
and other people
just looking at me like...
[ Laughter ]
And I couldn't tell anybod
the reason why I had them.
-You were like, "I'm not
mentally ill. It's for a part.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Congrats again on the show.
I'm so happy it's coming bac
for another season.
It's always so great to see you.
-It's always awesome to see you.